good morning believe nation today's
message is make meaning over to you guy
kawasaki the first thing i figured out
and learns sometimes the hard way about
entrepreneurship is that the core the
essence of entrepreneurship is about
making meaning many many people start
companies to make money the quick flip
the dot-com phenomena and I have noticed
in both the companies that I've started
and funded and been associated with that
those companies that that are
fundamentally founded to change the
world to make the world a better place
to make meaning are the companies that
make a difference they are the companies
to succeed my naive and romantic belief
is that if you make meaning you'll
probably make money but if you set out
to make money you will probably not make
meaning and you won't make money so my
first thought is you need to make
meaning that should be the core of why
you start a company there are three ways
to make meaning first is to increase the
quality of life my background is a
Macintosh division of Apple Computer and
I can tell you with total certainty that
we were not motivated by making money we
were motivated by changing the world to
make people more creative and more
productive we were trying to increase
the quality of life for the Macintosh
user and that was a great motivation it
kept us going through many many
difficult periods we were waking up in
the morning thinking how we could change
people's lives a second way to make
meaning is to right or wrong you know
that this fish is gonna die after
jumping out but to write a raw or means
that you find something that's wrong in
the world or you notice something that's
wrong around you want to fix that this
might be particularly applicable to
not-for-profits where you know there's
pollution or there's crime or there's
abuse and they just their very core is
to end that wrong and the third way to
make meaning is to prevent the end of
something good that you see something
beautiful something wonderful and you
just can't stand the fact that it's been
eroded it's being changed it's being
ruined so I ask you
you start your company's your
not-for-profits your churches your
schools whatever you're starting please
have one of those three motivations one
or more of those motivations if you
don't have any of those motivations I
suggest that you rethink what you're
doing so for those of you who've been on
my channel for a while you know this is
a message that's core to me and I felt
like I don't want to tell the same story
over and over and over and over again
but I didn't want to say one quick thing
I was in the comments section today and
a guy had left a comment on one of my
videos talking about me mentioning how
many subscribers I had in my channel and
he said I should stop making videos just
to get subscribers for the channel and
if you know anything about my channel
you know that I don't do this just to
get numbers there's a lot of stuff that
I could do a lot of cheap things I could
do on my videos to just try to boost the
subscriber count I want to feel proud
about the work that I'm doing right
everything that I make on this channel
is a reflection of me what I'm
interested in and if you guys with your
requests and and I want to be able to
look at the videos that I make and one
be inspired myself and to give ideas and
motivations and strategies to help other
entrepreneurs make meaningful changes in
their lives and I guess it bothered me
because I think too many entrepreneurs
are in it just for hitting numbers
hitting revenue targets hitting
subscriber numbers and do whatever it
takes without building anything that's
meaningful and concrete it makes them
feel good and it's a hollow victory and
you likely won't even get there but I
encourage you guys to do the things that
make you come alive and the things that
add meaning because it's it's so hard
being an entrepreneur and for those of
you who are already in it you know what
I'm talking about it's insanely
difficult to be an entrepreneur and the
only thing that gets you through to be
put that disproportionate amount of time
into what you're creating to eventually
see something do the thing that gets you
through that is the love for what you're
doing is the meaning in the work right
not just hopefully in the to hit this
end goal because you're going to quit
because it's too hard because you have
to face so much crap to get to where you
want to go the thing that gets you
through is the meaning in the work and
enjoying the process along so anybody
who suggests that you're in it just for
the numbers at least for me
you guys loyal audience no that's not
true and I really highly encourage you
guys to find something meaningful in
your work that makes you come alive so
the question of the day today is what is
the meaning in your work leaving the
comments below I'm curious to find out
I'm gonna join the discussion thank you
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of interest